[Music]
foreign
are you v please step in the vehicle
okay hello v
i'm jefferson perales you've already
spoken with elizabeth
my wife
so what do you got for me
carter let's go straight to the matter
at hand huh
my time's pretty valuable pretty sure
yours is too
true elizabeth well
as you're probably aware mayor lucius
ryan recently passed
we want to know how why whatever else is
pertinent
as far as i remember someone tried to
zero ryan a few days before his death
the ncpd sees no link they're saying it
was a random cyber psycho attack
and claim the mayor died of natural
causes causes unrelated to the attack
it's in the official reports ryan died
at home due to a cardio implant
malfunction
what makes you think the cops got it
wrong got any evidence
shortly before ryan passed he made cuts
in the ncpd budget
perhaps got on someone's bad side that
way in any case we have the cyber psycho
attack on a bd
our chief of security scanned it but
didn't find anything out of the ordinary
so to speak
we need a brain dance editor a real one
it's raw footage
the brain dance it has to be back where
it belongs today
where a lot of people will be in a lot
of trouble
if you agree to help you could see it
right now
all right see what i can do excellent
we'd be happy with any find that would
clarify things
alleviate lingering doubts
[Music]
well what do we got here question is
what are you doing here my brain too
isn't it
and this time don't go scrolling every
ass you see
eyes on the mayor stuff belongs to city
hall
who's the hulk guy no idea those ass
clowns are all the same
second conference in three days no idea
what this blitz is for
that's why i'm mayor and you're not
now's when we need the visibility
you're spreading yourself too thin i'll
rest
tonight my room at the red queen's race
is ready
yes of course good now go
out of practice red queen's race
cause any inner synapse zaps sure a
bunch of old brit farts and powdered
wigs shouting
off with their heads you know you're
allowed to say you don't have a clue
they left literally seconds before the
attack
and it looks planned like it was done on
purpose
that or the cyclist saw his chance and
took it don't get paranoid on me
stop right there
the cop wanted to tell security
something probably that he was standing
by to lick ryan's butthole
the terminal crashed right as he went
through the gate
glitch was no accident now seeing
stranger coincidences
like like when you bang some chick and
then her sister later
same night and it turns out they're both
sisters of god
that really happened to you no
but it could have
could have chromed half the city with
what he was packing
probably what happened buddy disappeared
from the morgue sight unseen
and then some pig got himself a new set
of wheels in an ugly ass
suit know that we're just talking about
your ass again
once you've seen all i've seen don't
need to know things to know
people are the same everywhere okay
it's coming at your ass
[Music]
well well well
do it after the conference
platoon don't recognize it tune
what he's honey wouldn't call that a
tune
he's really into it
[Music]
so
where there's
you're here fantastic
so any thoughts did you uh see anything
suspicious
anything at all or are we paranoid
whole thing stinks worse than coronado
bay in july
huh so suspicions confirmed
any questions at this point
cop who saved ryan know anything about
him
detective river ward good guy we worked
a few cases together
you want to talk to him i'll put you in
touch
mayor's hustle the ncpd no
all hand-picked by holt and on a corpse
payroll
but there are ex-cops among them
i i understand we'll catch up soon
now where did we leave off
anyone else besides ryan's detail have
access to the terminal
ncpd that's it
sheesh ward had great timing neither has
crazy good luck or had a source
got good info i'm gonna need some of
each
well said sending you his deeds
if you need anything else let us know
we'll help
in the city
this is ward who am i talking to name's
v
looking into the death of one lucious
rhine
wonder why you're not a cop
listen i know you tried to warn ryan
about the cyber psycho
what else do you know now that you best
meet with me
all right i'm head of the chubby
buffalos
be their stat
gun owners are reminded that the use of
firearms
[Music]
um
[Music]
my
[Music]
someone here to see you looks like
i wonder what about
[Music]
important one at the top you got a
minute
you must
[Music]
mind if we step off to decide on
me we're like one mind got no secrets
you really intend to work with a merc i
don't know what i intend just yet
now i'm gonna see if i hear anything new
about ryan's death
you back on that boss already told you
to drop it
you can say it again you know he hates
to say things twice
and if you couldn't give a rat's fat ass
about any of that keep my advice
as your friend just let the case go
you see me do anything i'm just sitting
here sipping coffee
fine do what you want
gotta go get my little girl and you two
at least find a quieter corner
okay talk
before the attack he wanted to talk to
ryan's hustle get some info dude
what was it let me ask you a question
first
why do you got your nose in this who
hired you
sorry never give up the names of my
clients
well then i'm sure you've got plenty of
other leads besides me
i mean i sure hope so cuz i'm not
telling you a thing
and i'm not being mean or nosy
nor is it personal discovering my own
ass
my own safety's at stake too so
before i open my mouth i need to know
whose ears are listening
liz perales hired me and her husband
jefferson the presumed future mayor
guess i could have seen that coming
you know what pawn was right acoustics
are a little too good in here
got my car outside okay
sure
some of the boys from the precinct saw
horvath around arroyo
shooting up dumpsters hollering how he's
gotta meet with the mayor
brought him in ron who win peter horvath
cyberpsycho who attacked the mayor later
he took him downtown but then he got
lost before they could get a statement
said he got lost how's that happen
what's it mean it means someone didn't
want him counting roaches in a cell that
day
before you ask me no i got no idea who
my turn why's perales looking at this
now
why is he want it done unofficial on the
hush hush
braless could just be scared doesn't
want the job of a guy who just got
carried out feet first who would
red queen's race heard anything about it
know what it is maybe i have maybe i do
it got anything to do with ryan the guy
was headed there the day he died
fine we're gonna see my ci
all i've heard at some fancy ass club no
idea where to even look for it
see i might know then we'll go talk to
the woman horvath worked for
or actually we could see her first
up to you
let's go see your informer club's a
better lead
fine with me
so
[Music]
my guy works here you go talk to him
i'll wait outside tell him igor says hi
he'll know what it's about all right
way to you then
you're looking for uh general
inspiration or something specific
because i can help with both
igor says hi [ __ ]
no said i was done i was out
hey neil this off
relax just got one question to ask you
nothing to see here sir come on
ghost i said let me alone got it
can't make me do a damn thing
we can actually and we will just tell us
where to find red queen's race
i don't know
you work retail right so you should be
able to count to two
two of us one of you tell us what we
want to know you won't need to learn
what it feels like not to have the upper
hand
at least not the hard way all right fine
chill it's outside city limits
near the river bonita street area you
been there made some deliveries
goods sometimes peeps we got no idea why
you want to go poking around there
club's empty he shut it all down
shut it down before or after mayor ryan
died
yeah soon after i guess thanks neil
[Music]
my [ __ ] luck well
well that's what i call a breakthrough
this seems promising but i'd still hit
that market
market morvath's employer what i
mentioned before
i just wouldn't let that leave drop
okay let's go see this market of yours
we're gonna take my car
better meet there fine with me
the ncpd advises those traveling beyond
official police jurisdiction to wear a
bulletproof vest at all times
don't go
um
cyberpsycho's boss you said christine
markov
42 vial has her as horvath's sole
employer
soul contact too actually come on
no idea who we're looking for i'm gonna
have to ask around
i'll start from the left and take the
right hola
christine markov
not get out
no she's over there
thanks
slow down
you christine markov we have some
questions
your badges
looking for data on paper horvet
work to your apparently yeah he did
then he stopped working started making
[ __ ] speeches all the time
these uh speeches what did he have to
say ryan
corbs got him by the balls and [ __ ] but
he still managed to [ __ ] me
his motto why'd he have it in for the
mayor
looking for reason in that whack job
probably thought ryan was
talking to him through the tv promising
all sorts of [ __ ] then cease him to give
a [ __ ]
so as horvath saw it who else had it in
for
besides ryan a madame president mostly
then arasaka the giza and when he died
it was a sun storm
wouldn't that be all detectives you're
spooking
had a personal beef with ryan
we might have guessed as much it might
seem like we didn't get a lot out of
that
but sometimes intel makes sense once
you've got some context
say for instance somebody says they got
it
minor detail means nothing but then the
guy waltzes straight into oncoming
traffic
labor remembers someone had worked on
the air conditioner in the guy's unit
guy whose head always hurt accident
coincidence or maybe air dispersed
poison
a deliberate hit you actually caught a
case like that
no made it up it still proves my point
[Music]
let me handle this v yo take off
[ __ ] off kitty claws
[ __ ] off
walking the streets with you downright
unsafe
got a beef with all gangs or just the
tigers
i'm a cop what do you think
good thing nobody got killed a little
less paperwork
okay red queen's race now go ride with
me
meet you there
[Music]
well hey
this is animal turf i can see that
lock up any of theirs recently not
lately no
but they're not big fans of pigs either
i can't go in without a warrant
but you uh-huh
all right be in touch you find anything
tell me
this [ __ ] off
nothing to see here
[Music]
looking for a club red queen's race
closed not opening anytime soon either
so it's fine if i have a look around
inside no it ain't
no looking just delta the [ __ ] out of
here
looks like a normal body shop to me
club's here i'm telling you tell me
you've got a hunch
cop intuition something like that
everything okay got spotted
okay hang on be right there
[Music]
chip dash
hmm
neil doesn't tend to lie
so the club's around here somewhere in
the garage is my guess
we're under it
[Music]
yes
down
hmm
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you god user
[Music]
hmm
so
mr stein
[Music]
so
look at that
uh
whatever it was that went down
[ __ ]
kicks hard
bruh
make him [ __ ] bad
oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
i gotta do the talking you're the
detective
but i don't have a warrant right
[Music]
lucius ryan recently deceased mayor of
night city
he was here the night he died maybe he
was
maybe he wasn't no [ __ ] idea
but hey you might be here the day you
die joking
why are you watching this dumb nothing
left to clap here we ain't watching it
[ __ ] waiting for what till they send
us the scratch for a job well done
smashed it up pretty [ __ ] good didn't
we we done our fit
time for the pay-up
who would you smash it up for ah what's
it to you
i might be able to speed up your payment
the [ __ ] i look like to you
someone who'd swallow scott like that
wanna buy this dump turn it into
something real elegant and green
a little hard with you sitting here
though isn't it so i wouldn't mind
speeding your transaction on its way
first though gotta know who owes you
lucius ryan's right right-hand bulletary
candidate for mayor in the upcoming
election
fight [ __ ] it for the job thanks for the
help
music
[Music]
ah
come on you hear me breathe
oh
you ask me one heart attack that killed
ryan
yeah as i said from the start but
someone spiked his bd that's what killed
him
[ __ ] i think you could be right
come on v
looks like an office sort of comps are
what we want
comps above all
yep stiff is a board you ask me he's
been dead at least an hour
no no trauma cut pretty sure he didn't
bring it on purpose
ah club like this you don't want tt
banging down the door when you're
banging away and things start to heat up
hard probably must have gotten a little
too heavy and messy
okay yeah let's do that coroner will
find him at home
i'll tell him how to write it up boys
are getting him out of here
of course nobody yeah
weird guy looks familiar doesn't he
v i'm not in the mood for jokes
i think we've seen everything we needed
to
let's go
okay that's delta i think i saw another
way out on the way in
[Music]
[ __ ]
still hanging around
ah what's the matter remember why do you
even care
your conscience is clear
you know why because i took all the
responsibility
you got no idea how this city works
think a goddamn
inspirational idealist [ __ ] actually
means something
it doesn't never did
hey don't look at me that way merc
you know i'm right
i know this town inside out so you know
how it works
at city hall in the street those are the
same
ryan knew it too he fought for the city
cleanly at times dirty at others
but always with a lot of heart
wouldn't have wanted him to get dragged
through the muck
ryan was an [ __ ] but an [ __ ] who
got [ __ ] done
i remember what it was like before he
was elected also remember who stopped
the militech panzers when the nusa tried
to annex
night city v
appreciate the help but this isn't your
best
i'll take care of it how are you gonna
do that
am i under arrest got a scroll got a
motive got your confession
so yeah you could be but it wouldn't
make much sense
you don't even gotta say who ordered you
to go and clean up
i know anyway so since even our brass's
fingers are all over this
i gotta take it to internal they won't
do a thing either
not to me they'll put you in their
sights though
just go home ward get some sleep
find all this easier to take in in the
morning i mean
that's my plan
[ __ ]
so what now we'll let this go
can't holtz murdered ryan
wanted his seat mold his tritest motive
in the book
that's why i believe it use the ncpd to
cover his tracks
also think it was halt only one who
stood to gain
ticking this to internal affairs got
enough to get this case reopened
do it and you gonna report back to the
paralysis
yep okay i'm gonna stay observe a little
thanks fee
so about ryan got a pretty good idea
what happened
great come by please it's a sensitive
matter i'd rather discuss it face to
face
we'll be waiting
[Music]
oh
we're upstairs thanks
just gonna tell you one thing
i'm listening don't tell them nothing
don't get involved
this mug is deeper than you think suck
you in if you're not
careful
i'm always careful fine do whatever the
[ __ ] you want
not like you listen anyway
hello v please come in make yourself at
home
jefferson will join us shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please have a seat
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
see ya v
elizabeth tells me you have answers for
us i'm all ears
it's not 100 clear what happened hardly
anything ever is
but yeah i got some idea
[Music]
v i think weldon holt was behind ryan's
death
i knew it you got any proof i don't
just uh strong suspicions that's all we
need to know jeff
we have to be careful keep a close eye
on holt
and up our security you're right as
always
you're right thanks for your help fee
your fee
you two watch out for each other
hey there now where did we leave off
careful please
right
like